The Joe Rogan Experience when we sued
Monsanto
there's a there's a there's many many
diseases that are linked to glyphosate
exposure
including
um uh
non-alcoholic fatty liver cancer is a
very very closely linked
um a lot of kidney diseases
and then severe damage to the micropion
because
it's designed to kill plants
um
uh
and it and and there are
there are structures in your
um
in your gut biome that are critical
structures in your gut biome
which have plant-like metabolisms which
are destroyed by glyphosate
and so you know what what happened is
um
life is a and glyphosate was a it was
originally developed as a as a
tank scaleant so to to scale the calcium
calcium and other deposits metal
deposits rest deposits from the inside
of
you know underground tanks and in 1973
uh
Monsanto had to stop producing DDT
because you know we passed the laws at
that time and it that was its Flagship
product it needed another product
and I figured out that glyphosate
somebody at some point apparently threw
some glyphosate on the you know out in
the back in the yard and everything like
green died where they touched it where
it touched if it say
and so somebody said oh this will be a
good herbicide because it kills all
plants
originally Monsanto developed it as a as
a uh as a herbicide but the way that it
was applied initially from 1973 to 1993
was in backpack sprayers so guys would
walk down the cornfield cornrows
early in the season when the corn was
competing with nearby weeds for her
sunlight
and they would shoot the individual
weeds and then in 93 somebody figured
out a way that that glyphosate
there was certain bacteria that
glyphosate would not kill
and they said we could take a gene out
of that bacteria and put it into a corn
seed and develop a corn that cannot be
killed by glyphosate
so they developed Roundup Ready corn
and that corn you can pork glyphosate
all over it and it will do nothing to it
so now you could fire all of those
workers who were expensive
and you hire one airplane and they fly
over the fields they saturate the entire
landscape with glyphosate everything
dies except the Roundup Ready corn
and within a couple of years Roundup
Ready corn was now on ninety percent of
the Corn 95 of corn in the United States
is now Roundup Ready corn
and so but it was still being and then
they developed it for soybean and for
um and for uh barley for sorghum for a
lot of other plants
but it was still being applied early in
the season
and then in 2000 around 2006
they discovered that if you sprayed it
on wheat late in the season it would
desiccate the wheat in other words it
would dry it out and one of the big
losses for Farmers is weed is if it
rains during the harvest season
you can't Harvest it because it gets
moldy and so if you can spray a dead
skin on it and dries it out and kills it
you can Harvest it right away and it
won't get moldy
so all the wheat in our country started
being sprayed that year in 2006 with
glyphosate and that's the year you saw
this explosion of celiac diseases and uh
you know gluten allergies and all of
this stuff that people you know that you
may have noticed around then but they
also the first time they were and excuse
me the first time they're they're
spraying it directly on food because it
used to be they were spraying it early
in the season
and it would you know it would wash off
and the corn would get higher than the
weeds and you wouldn't have to do it but
but now they're spraying it directly on
our food sorry okay no it's okay
um so what they
when they when they started doing this
is there's a direct result like you can
see the increase in Celiac disease you
can see is this like documented well no
these are
no that's not documentary but these are
there are there's a whole range of
diseases that are now you know the
people are are the science at different
levels of science
have linked to glyphosate exposure
here's the thing and when you litigate
you when you when you're suing somebody
for a chemical exposure
you have to go through a a
threshold called the dalbert hearing and
the dalbert hearing is a hearing that
says
is there sufficient science that it's
now considered kind of mainstream
that we can show this to a jury and the
judge has to make that decision because
the judge doesn't want people saying you
know coming in and saying uh
you know uh
allowed noises made me crazy right right
you there has to be before and and then
a good attorney might be able to
convince a jury that yeah this my client
got crazy because he heard a loud noise
so the judge needs to make a threshold
decision about whether there's
sufficient signs to show a jury and that
is a very high threshold
of all of the diseases that are probably
caused probably almost certainly caused
by glyphosate the only one to pass that
threshold
was the case that we bought for
um for Hodgkin on Hodgkin's lymphoma so
at that point we had enough rad studies
enough human studies we had about 10 of
each
and we were able to go to the judge and
say this we got enough signs on this now
to show that it's uh that that nine
hodgkinson pump is being caused by
glyphosate so that those were the only
cases we brought
the other thing but there are a lot of
of you know really interesting studies
that show links between
injuries to children and the uh and the
amount of glyphosate in a woman's urine
and the mother's urine you know
including a lot of uh uh including
um sexual development it's an angiogram
disruptor
so
um you know similar to phthalates
accolades are in disruption probably the
most disturbing endocrine disruptor and
this is something we should all be
looking at is atrazine yeah because
atrazine which is now ubiquitous is
everywhere
but you can take atrazine and there you
know this you you what is this Jamie
Jamie young Jamie you can look up
you can look up this study I think the
guy the scientist's name is Tyler I
think and that might be his first or
second name
but they took atrazine
and they put it in a tank with 40 frogs
for yeah three years
they put it below the exposure levels
that EPA considers acceptable to humans
and 30 of those frogs they were all male
frogs and they were double z you know
male frogs so they were super males
and 30 of those frogs were chemically
castrated
four of them turned into females and
produced fertile eggs
so they took male frogs gave them
actress in 10 percent of them turned
into female and produced fertile eggs
and we're subjecting our children
to exposure to that every day what is
atrazine it's in the water it's a
pesticide
here it is report toxic herbicide found
in many Texans drinking water
that's it that's from 2018 November 20th
yeah and what you know what does this do
to sexual development in children nobody
knows because we know what it does to
frogs